hey Sharon do you know that in England
they actually don't call an elevator an
elevator
do you know what they call it
no it's an elevatoro
we'll see what the people think good
morning tickets Tuesday on Friday I gave
the theologyist speech of my life at
Harvard's Memorial Church and then
boarded a flight for London where our
family saw plow Lane for the first time
a Stadium built by its fans for a club
AFC Wimbledon owned by its fans the
highlight of the match itself was
unquestionably the double rainbow that
graced us with its presence in the
second half Wimbledon lost one nil and
never much looked like scoring as the
game ended my daughter looked up at me
and I expected her to tell me that it
was such a bummer to fly all this way
just to see the Dons lose a fourth tier
soccer game but in fact she said that
was amazing also Sarah took this
ridiculously perfect picture it was just
thrilling to be there to see the
physical embodiment of what a community
can accomplish when it sticks together
and has a shared purpose getting plow
Lane a truly magnificent Stadium built
was not easy or straightforward word
volunteers worked for two decades on
everything from fundraising to planning
approval it was hard and complicated and
messy and full of setbacks and
discouragements but when your work is
grounded in solidarity and love it's
incredible what you can accomplish so
yeah we lost on the day we've lost on a
lot of days recently but plow Lane
itself is an extraordinary Victory
anyway then we waited on a train
platform for the train to emerge out of
the darkness like a metaphor and then we
took one of those London escalators that
rather resembles an escalator to heaven
and made our way to the freeze London
art fair which is perhaps the snootiest
event ever to occur inside of a tent but
nonetheless there was lots of great art
there and I was especially drawn to the
Landscapes including these breath
stealingly gorgeous paintings by the
Brazilian artist Lucas Aruda and this
highly abstracted landscape by the
American Artist Byron Kim this
beautifully strange undersea scape by
the Haitian artist Diddy a William
astonished me as did the Cuban artist
Johann capote's landscape made of
plaster and recycled metal even this
lovely painting by the American Sam
Moyer combining stones and canvas seemed
to kind of place picture to me as if the
whole show was telling me touch grass
and so we went outside London was
absurdly autumnal just like Indianapolis
is this time of year we walked and
chatted and I kept thinking about how to
talk about the world this world with
grass what is the opposite of a
metaverse the uh Terror verse I love the
internet I have made such wonderful
friends here and had so many deep and
real experiences but the internet is a
compliment to the terror verse not a
replacement for it look at this light
these trees and then know that out there
wherever you are the light is more Vivid
and the trees More Alive than they can
ever be on YouTube when I was recovering
from labyrinthitis my physical therapist
told me to go outside for a few minutes
a day at the time my brain was having to
relearn balance and to do so it relied
more on visual cues than it had in the
past so I was easily overwhelmed by
visual information and I would become
immediately dizzy because there was just
so much visual information the leaves
wobbling in the wind squirrels running
clouds moving light shifting I still
sometimes get vertigo when the quantity
of visual information gets too high
but I need to be outside I need to be in
the world
and to remember that I am of it
Hank I'll see you on Friday